go talk to nine-year-olds they regret
they talk about regret I wish is the
opening line hey man tell me about your
life literally I wish one by one at
airport at Airport park or park event or
event bar or bar every one of them every
one of them all of them started with I
wish all of them I wish they grew up in
a generation that did not have the
Internet it was not practical to do all
the amazing things we could be doing
they all wished they wish they worked
harder they wish they spent more time
with their family they wish they didn't
listen to their mom and did what they
wanted to do mine without my mom even
knowing it my mom didn't want to it
didn't want to let me go
last day I keep on pushing keep on
cruising keep on pushing
she lets me go
they wished they wished they wished the
biggest poison in us is regret it's
poison and I push so hard so hard and
we'll through my vehicle which isn't
meditation which isn't health and
wellness which is a nonprofit my
vehicles business I can't help it it's
what I love I love building businesses I
love competing with you I want to beat
you I love that game but through that
vehicle I will always push a lack of
regret and awareness to how good it
really is you're more than welcome to
tell me about how bad it is or why you
can't because or what but it's just not
true because if anybody ever did it then
you can't